[Music]  we should talk about something exciting  the City of Pasadena which is where the  Big Bang Theory takes place the setting  declared tomorrow February 25th The Big  Bang Theory day yeah this means  apparently I don't know what's in that  means I think you can walk into any  store and have anything for free  yourself to anything or anyone yeah also  you can't commit any crimes you want in  Pasadena  but anyway also this is true they sent  us the sign like a street it's a  stepping stone to it why do they have to  go out of their way to say I'll be  living under it one day they're trying  to keep them humble yeah that's very  nice yeah do you remember we got a onin  show sign cuz there's like five years  ago were you a Boulevard no check it out  this is a real picture of what we got it  [Applause]  that is really  [Applause]  North High is really what we got what's  a North Hollywood yeah it's something  like that yeah yeah I love the razor  wire